hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast when good biomarkers go bad
effectively utilizing procalcitonin PCT
for sepsis management to demonstrate the
value of the lab i'm christina joel of
lab routes and I'll be your moderator
for today's event we are delighted to
bring you this lab leaders webinar
series educational event presented by
lab routes and sponsored by Roche
Diagnostics lab leaders we have a few
important announcements before we begin
this webcast is designed to be
interactive and we encourage you to ask
questions during the event you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window we will
try to answer as many questions as we
can you can enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window
now if you have any technical problems
viewing or hearing this presentation
please click on the support button at
the top right of your presentation
window or just submit your problem
through the green Q&A button on the
lower left this is an educational
webinar and thus offers free continuing
education credits when the webinar is
over please click on the C e button
located at the bottom left hand corner
of your webpage and follow the process
of taming your credit now with no
further ado let's get started as a
global leader in health care Roche
Diagnostics has made the promise to
empower laboratories and the people
within them by providing clinical and
strategic insights support and solutions
from the industry's top innovators
through lab leaders calm today's
presentation when good biomarkers go bad
effectively using PCT and chef's
management to demonstrate the value of
the lab focuses on the opportunity high
medical value biomarkers like PCT
present for lab leaders to lead in the
efforts to recognize and manage sepsis
the number one cause and
in hospitals our presenter dr. dr. Josh
Hayden is an assistant professor of
pathology and Laboratory Medicine at the
Weill Cornell Medical College where he
serves as the director of the toxicology
and therapeutic drug monitoring
laboratory and assistant director of the
central laboratory at New York
Presbyterian Hospital he received his
PhD from Carnegie Mellon University
conducted postdoctoral research at the
Massachusetts Institute of Technology
and completed a clinical chemistry
fellowship at the University of
Washington in Seattle his research is
focused on improving patient care
through the development and
implementation of advanced diagnostics I
will now turn it over to dr. Hayden for
his presentation dr. Hayden thank you
very much for the introduction and thank
you for joining us here for a talk on
procalcitonin just to start a little
disclaimer I think this is Roush's way
of mentioning that some of the things I
say will be my opinion and so if they're
incorrect or stupid that's not that's
not their fault so just blame that on me
also was paid an honorarium by Roche to
give this presentation so when we think
about biomarkers I wanted to start with
a situation that some of us might be
familiar with I think about troponin as
a biomarker and whether it's useful in
the scenario depicted here if a patient
come into our emergency department at
say 9:10 p.m. on a Saturday the
clinician order saponin maybe within 20
minutes the samples run process by the
lab within 20 minutes again and then
it's placed in Iraq to be run in a batch
with a number of other troponin received
throughout that busy Friday night on
Saturday morning at which point about 11
hours later it's resulted as being high
I think the question is was troponin a
useful biomarker in this situation which
I guess begs the question what is a
useful biomarker
I took this from 2016 advances in
precision medicine and I think it lays
out rather nicely what it takes to be
considered a useful biomarker the first
is going to be the biologic validity so
does the analyte analyte make biologic
sense for the pathology being considered
in that area I don't think there's any
argument that cardiac troponin is a
biologically valid biomarker it's a good
indicator of cardio myocyte damage the
second is analytic validation so can the
analyte we're interested in be reliably
detected at relevant concentrations in
the samples were hoping to analyze it
and third is the clinical validation so
this would be the sensitivity
specificity if you want to think about
it that way does the analyte actually
turn out to provide some value when
you're looking at the intended patient
population and in terms of value that
really lies in the fourth one which is
the clinical utility so does the analyte
provide information that improves
patient outcome or reduces the cost of
care and I think that last one reducing
the cost of care is especially important
as we move into the sort of affordable
care error we always need to be asking
ourselves what we're doing that doesn't
contribute to high-value care and what
we should be doing to contribute to
high-value care so if we if you're
wondering if you're in the right right
webinar you are we are going to be
talking about procalcitonin not dwelling
on MI and one of the reasons for that is
rates of hospital admissions for sepsis
far exceed those of myocardial
infarction and Stroke combined if we're
looking on the left as the adjusted
rates for EMS admission for 100
encounters you can see that sepsis is
more than double those of stroke and MI
so perhaps not surprisingly given the
high incidence
also has a high mortality it's the
leading cause of death in the United
States with estimated at over 700,000
deaths annually due to sepsis with the
high mortality and high incidence it's
perhaps not surprising that there's also
a very high tops of care in fact it's
actually the major cause of healthcare
expenditure and organizations are
starting to think actively about what
they can do to manage sepsis and so just
a quick polling question for you do you
sit on your organization sepsis
committee the answer yes no or our
Hospital does not have a substance
committee that third option would also
count if you're not sure if a substance
committee exists so looking at the cost
of sepsis you can see that the average
is about $22,000 per patient over twenty
billion dollars annually certainly with
numbers like this CMS is really
beginning to evaluate how it can start
to improve both the cost of care and the
quality and we'll talk about some of
your things that labs can bring to the
table as we look to improve our medical
centers ability to to contribute to this
so that's interesting it looks like the
majority of you actually do not have
don't sit on the sepsis committee in
your Hospital and only a small
percentage don't have or are unsure
so this brings us to our learning TOC
learning objectives for today's talk so
by the end of this webinar the hope is
that you'll be able to summarize the
requirements and the implications of the
new CMS core measures finally to then to
explain the role that procalcitonin can
play in identifying bacteria as a source
of sepsis start to think about the
clinical performance required for
procalcitonin to really be a useful
biomarker for sepsis and finally
understand how lab leadership position
procalcitonin with key stakeholders to
maximize adoption and clinical utility
so in terms of the new CMS core measure
them to be helpful to first put this
into perspective of the challenge of
improving sepsis management so it's good
to keep in mind that substance is a
clinical syndrome it's not a pathologic
entity necessarily it's not as simple as
this is adenocarcinoma
this is Addison's disease it's a
syndrome
it's the unregulated immune response to
a life-threatening infection it's
incredibly challenging to even define
sepsis right let alone diagnosis we do
have the third international consensus
definitions which are referenced there
which I would definitely direct you to
the way I like to think about it is well
the way I like think about most things
is going to be in Venn diagrams right so
if we think about starting with a
patient who has two or more symptoms
sirs or systemic inflammatory response
syndrome could be elevated heart rate
elevated white cell count and then if
you have a confirmed or suspected
infection and this word suspected is
important because we know from studies
that a large number of infections are
never diagnosed for the laboratory about
40 percent of patients with bacteremia
and never have a confirmed organism on
microbiologic evaluation
but certainly with changing technologies
in the microbiology lab that number is
reducing but as you can imagine that
starts to make having a gold standard
for sepsis incredibly challenging
patients with sepsis can then progress
into severe sepsis where you have low
systolic blood pressure or symptoms of
end organ damage and then finally those
with severe sepsis can move into septic
shock if they have persistent signs of
severe sepsis so if we think about
sepsis as a continuum I'm starting with
sepsis and ending at multiple organ
function syndrome ultimately death of
the patient farther along our patients
are on this continuum the higher the
mortality you can see 27 percent for
substance versus 54 percent for septic
shock so what we'd like to know
certainly is where the patient is along
this continuum so we can give the
appropriate level of intervention and we
can detect those who are more likely to
progress and the sooner we can do that
the better with sepsis and this is an
important point time is key with sepsis
so this is from a 2011 critical care
paper which looked at the running
average of survival on the y-axis versus
delays in the administration of
effective antibiotics after the onset of
septic shock and what they found was
that every our antibiotics are delayed
in sepsis increases the mortality
approximately 8 percent right and so
some of you might be thinking well the
answer is obvious right patient comes in
the door and we give everybody
broad-spectrum antibiotics and you might
be thinking that if you've been living
on a rock and haven't necessarily heard
that the problem of antimicrobial
resistance is becoming increasingly
prevalent you can see the science news
report talking about the slow
catastrophic slow catastrophe as the
Golden Age of antibiotics come
to an end so for this reason a lot of
our medical centers have put in place
antibiotic stewardship committee so now
our second poll question do you sit on
your organization's antibiotic
stewardship committee yes no or your
hospital doesn't have it and once again
if you're unsure if your Hospital has it
you can click our hospital does not have
and antibiotic stewardship committee and
so there's a lot of things that we need
to start to consider when were
confronted with a patient who might be
septic right this is going to be
reducing unnecessary prescribing of
antibiotics for those who don't have
sepsis and making sure we get it quickly
to those who do have it so looking at
the pool that's interesting again the
bulk of folks do not sit on the
antibiotic stewardship committee so I
think you'll find as we go on that
procalcitonin has a lot of utility which
folks on these programs might be
interested in and I would suggest
finding them in your organization
because they can really be helpful
allies as you start to think about
implementing this so in the effort to
improve care for sepsis CMS has released
a new core measure so what our core
measures the core measures are
evidence-based standards of care which
have been shown to improve patient
outcomes all hospitals are required to
report data on their compliance with
these standards of care so the way
they're reported were to have a
denominator which is all of the patients
who are eligible to receive those
standards of care and the numerator is
going to be the number of patients who
actually receive the care many of these
measures are what they call all or
nothing so if there's nine standards of
care and you administered eight that
still counts as a zero Nucor measures
are enforced through financial penalties
the financial penalties apply whether
you fail to report or fails in
the published core measure and the
penalties tend to be a percentage of
reimbursement as many of us in the lab
know a small percentage on very big
numbers is a substantial amount sepsis
core measures which we'll talk about
next we're introduced in 2015 for data
gathering but the penalties we'll be
applying in fiscal year 2017 so what are
these core measures so they're severe
sepsis core measure which is an
all-or-nothing measure defines two time
points at which hospitals must meet
certain criteria so within three hours
of patient recognition lactate needs to
be measured blood cultures need to be
obtained twice prior to the start of
antibiotics and then antibiotic IV
antibiotics need to be started within
six hours of patient recognition so
three hours later a repeat lactate must
be done if the initial lactate was
greater than two I'll mention there's
still a lot of debate and discussion
about these core measures there's really
no great criteria for how time zero is
defined you can imagine if you have a
questionable time zero it's hard to know
when something was done three hours from
it and that same criticism applies with
the septic shock measure where time zero
once again is going to be challenging to
define with this septic shock we have
those same two time points where
hospitals must meet certain criteria so
within three hours of recognizing septic
shock you need to do everything that was
in the severe sepsis bundle as well as
fluid resuscitation if the patient is
hypotensive and then within less within
six hours just like the last bundle
their lactate must be repeated if the
initial was greater than two you have to
start days oppressors for unresponsive
hypotension and check volume status and
perform tissue perfusion assessment if
the lactate is greater than four or
there's persistent hypotension
so what can labs do in terms of
addressing sepsis right beyond these
core measures and particularly what is
the role of procalcitonin and could it
serve as a good biomarker for substance
so let's go back to our illustration of
what makes something a good biomarker
right you'll find I like to repeat
things a lot so my apologies for those
paying attention but I tend to have a
short attention span so I find bringing
slides up over and over again can be
helpful these are the questions we need
to ask when we're thinking about whether
or not procalcitonin is a useful
biomarker for sepsis let's start with
biological basis so procalcitonin it's a
hundred and sixteen amino acid precursor
to calcitonin produced by primal cells
in response to microbial toxins or hosts
immune responses so you can see a
depiction of the protein on the left and
what I'm showing on the right is a graph
of procalcitonin levels in response to
different hosts immune responses such as
il beta which induces a robust response
right so that's good because we know we
have a good biological validity for this
biomarker selectively expressed in
response bacterial infections as well as
host immune responses which we know make
up the clinical syndrome sepsis so what
about analytic validation can we
actually measure this accurately what
I'll be showing here is some data using
the recently released Roche
procalcitonin assay we obviously want to
be measuring this and in patient samples
so serum or plasma so we have our big
three interferences we want to be
concerned with I hope any of my
residents listening could list these
without any problems so this is going to
be a curious hemolysis like Pia Mia
those are all not going to affect the
assay and then biotin is also looked at
because the assay uses a biotin
streptavidin approach and biotin also
does not cause any problems and that's
helpful for anybody who's red cap today
and is aware of the growing biotin
fashion fad which is causing all of
these folks to use massive amounts of
biotin in the hopes of getting fairer
scan or nicer hair or I'm not sure what
it does other than interfere with some
of our lab results and waste their money
but nice we know the biotin doesn't
interfere furthermore when we're looking
at the potential interference of
commonly used pharmaceuticals in this
patient population no interference the
assay was found and our lower limits of
measurement with limit of detection and
the limit of quantitation are excellent
so having a good limit of quantitation
is certainly great but with
procalcitonin we want to be able to
sometimes monitor patients over time so
as important as the limit of
quantitation is going to be the
precision of our assays right so what is
the CV I'm showing here some performance
data from multiple Roche platforms and
you can see we're looking at
concentrations which span the range of
our AMR from down near the lower end
0.79 top around 88 nanograms per mil and
in all cases except for the lowest
levels tested we have seen these below
five and even at the lowest level tested
we have C B's well below 10 so this is
excellent precision and reproducibility
so so we have an assay which can
quantify procalcitonin in samples of
interest at the necessary levels right
so we have two down which I will point
out that for many biomarkers that's not
always the case right I'm thinking about
some of the interleukins
in particular there for analytic
validation but we'll focus on
procalcitonin so two down what about the
clinical validation so what studies have
been done to look at the sensitivity and
specificity
in the intended patient population I
think it's good to step back for a
minute and remember the challenge we're
asking of a biomarker for sepsis right
this is challenging to define let alone
diagnose it's a clinical syndrome we
have confirmed or suspected infection
questionable gold standard for the
diagnosis of sepsis this is not a
straightforward question still I think
you'll see the procalcitonin is done
quite well if we look at some of the
published data so if we look for
instance at the receiver operating
characteristic curve for serum
biomarkers in this case I'm looking at
procalcitonin CRP interleukin 6 and
lactate and we look at the performance
this is the sensitivity for specificity
in the ROC plot you can see PCT has
excellent diagnostic performance I think
one of the better studies is a recent
meta-analysis which was done which
pooled a large number of studies which
had been done both prospective and
retrospective and it found an overall
area under the curve of 0.85 so this was
a resident lecture this is where I would
ask my residents to tell me what the AUC
means since it's not a resident lecture
it's a-me monologuing here for a while I
will just mention that it is going to be
integration of the area under the ROC
plot shown to the left an AUC of 0.5 is
going to be a terrible diagnostic test
an AZ of 1 is going to be excellent now
beyond looking at sensitivity and
specificity of procalcitonin for sepsis
remember we also want to remember that
sepsis is a continuum and so can be
helpful to know where on this continuum
patients are and whether or not they're
progressing along the continuum so can
procalcitonin do that for us can it help
us predict those patients who are most
likely to be at higher risk of mortality
so that we can intervene which with more
aggressive energy
in the ICU so looking at some of that
data and the table shown here on the
right is actually taken out of the
package insert what we're looking at
here now is the Delta or change in
procalcitonin from the first day or day
zero of ICU admission - the
procalcitonin level on day four all of
which divided by that initial
procalcitonin level so what we found was
that in patients diagnosed with severe
sepsis or septic shock if we actually
had the procalcitonin changed by greater
than 80% then we would consider the test
negative and those patients had a
significant lower mortality risk whereas
if the Delta procalcitonin was less than
or equal to 80 then the test was
positive and those patients were at a
higher risk for mortality so that's
great so now we know that procalcitonin
has shown acceptable sensitivity and
specificity for sepsis it can help us
start to identify those patients at a
greater risk for mortality so what about
the final one clinical utility which is
does this provide information that
improves patient outcome or reduces the
cost of patient care and so this is our
next teaching point the other way I like
to think about this is what do we as
laboratory and need to do in terms of
offering this test for it to be
impactful and towards that end I wanted
to bring us back to that troponin
scenario I present it right troponin is
and can be a good biomarker but in this
scenario I would argue and I don't think
anybody would contest me on this that
it's not a clinically useful biomarker
because of that 11:00 hour turnaround
time this is what I would describe as a
good biomarker gone bad
it has good performance but the way it's
utilized in the lab isn't actually
helping our patient
so what can we do about that I think
most of you have done exactly what we've
done
which is address that long turnaround
time so we do in our Hospital let's say
that same patient comes in Friday night
10 p.m. within 20 minutes they have
their troponin ordered within 20 minutes
it's spun and loaded onto our instrument
stat so that within about 20 minutes we
can have the troponin result in the
patient's medical records so in my
institution we are strokes on our
excellence and part of that means us
closely monitoring our door to lab
result time and we've been managed we've
managed to achieve greater than 90% of
our troponin results coming from the
stroke panels in under 60 minutes how
are we able to do this well so the first
is we have a dedicated random access
analyzer so this is an instrument which
does other analyses which is helpful
because that way I can justify having
the technologists actually working there
and knowing how to use it
we certainly don't batch our components
we make sure that the testing is offered
24/7 and then this instrument allows us
to perform some of these other relevant
tasks such as troponin RH CGS as well as
i/o PTH it's all done on a single
instrument so I can justify the
resources to actually handle those and
run them stat right away once again
we're not gonna be talking about
troponin right why am I thinking so much
about your phonin when really if I'm
worried about lab tests for folks coming
into my emergency department sepsis is
far and away a bigger cause of concern
so what am i doing to report one of
these useful biomarkers of sepsis
procalcitonin so unfortunately our
current testing really is not providing
any clinical value to our patient or our
health system but I don't think I'm
alone on this so you can see we have
another poll how often is broke out
the tone and testing offered in your
hospital did you offer it 24/7 is it one
or more times per day less than one so
what today or we do not currently
perform procalcitonin testing in our lab
so I can tell you if I were to answer
this I would pick option two one or more
times per day so we do offer at seven
days a week but it's batch run at 9:00
a.m. 11 a.m. and 2 p.m. I'll be
interested to know if folks here on this
webinar just want to know how to improve
programs of tone and testing or actually
thinking about bringing it in let's see
what folks said so it looks like a
little over half of you do not currently
perform procalcitonin testing in your
lab although I have to say I am
impressed that almost a third offer it
24/7 which I would argue is really the
way you have to offer procalcitonin
testing for it to be useful so the
situation that we have currently at my
institution when we receive the sample
it's going to sit and be batched at
those three defined time points what
this means is we have poor availability
an incredibly long turnaround times so
our median turnaround time is 6 hours
and if you look at the graph on the
right I should mention this graph was
prepared by one of our pathology
residents Michael Novak who has an
interest in this you can see that the
turnaround time and hours extends well
past at 10:00 hour mark we have a decent
number of results with turnaround times
in the 10 to 15 hour range or longer
based on what might happen with the
instrument so why is this so currently
art procalcitonin testing is performed
on what I refer to as an orphan
instrument so this is our Vitus it's an
instrument which doesn't do much if any
necessary testing besides that single
analyte and that means all of my SOPs
all of my maintenance all of my employee
proficiency to
seeing all of the lis interface the cap
checklist associated with these
instruments are all done for a single
assay beyond that I can't really justify
the resources to have someone 24/7
running that as samples come in and
that's why we have been batching these
so what do we have to do to make this a
clinically useful biomarker so I think
we need to do exactly what most
hospitals have done for their cardiac
markers we need to have this available
on a dedicated random access analyzer so
we can offer testing 24/7 with rapid
turnaround time right that way when the
patient comes in with concerns for
sepsis any hour of the day into the IDI
receive the sample we spin it loaded
stat and we get a result which can help
the clinician direct management of that
patient in order to do that you really
need a single instrument which can do
more than one test right in my ideal
world
I'm already dedicating the time and
resources to stat loading troponin
on a single instrument as well as stat
loading my HC G's if I could just add
procalcitonin to that list my life would
become substantially easier the
operational burdens of the lab would be
diminished because I could be done with
that orphaned instrument and I would be
able to improve the service we're
offering because I could have a door to
result for procalcitonin in under 60
minutes ideally my Tech's tell me they'd
also like to see us reduce that
incubation time of the IOP th well 17
minutes seems relatively fast and told
when you have an irate surgeon calling
you every two minutes for a result that
faster is always better so I guess a
question though is is a door to result
of 60 minutes something that just sort
of picked at random where is this
something which I think has some basis
so there was some work done by Good Hope
hospital over in the UK
and they instituted what they term the
sepsis six so this is a bundle of six
standards so high blow oxygen blood
cultures IV antibiotics you can see many
of them made their way into the CMS
sepsis core bundle which were all
supposed to be delivered within one hour
and when they looked at their data they
found that those patients receiving that
bundle within one hour had half the
mortality of those not receiving the
bundle within one hour and this is why I
really feel that the laboratory markers
for sepsis demand that random-access
rapid turnaround time in an hour or less
if possible to have some real clinical
value Phil I know many of us are used to
having these is analytes that we'd like
to bring in-house and there's always
this this question with the the
stakeholders right we're going to be
potentially asking for additional
resources or expanding our test menu
which sometimes requires resources as
well so how do we position this so that
we can maximize adoption and the
clinical utility well I want to remind
you about the cost of sepsis right
median cost per patient of
22,000 leading healthcare expenditure by
condition and what I'll say here is this
22,000 dollars that's not the lab
testing that's treatment this is where I
would like to mention to folks that
detecting sepsis identifying sepsis
early is not expensive treating sepsis
is incredibly expensive and the longer
it takes you to treat the longer that
patient is going to need to be treated
and the higher the mortality they're
going to suffer and this has been borne
out in the literature we look at some
findings so this is one example out of
the literature of the references at the
end where they instituted an early
recognition and treatment of sepsis
program so point out that this is an
early recognition program so this is
having defined signs such as vital signs
heart rates what
etc and not entirely leveraging some of
the biomarkers which are out there you
can see in the before group they had a
median cost per patient of just about
$22,000 without the recognition program
although you'll notice the box and
whisker plots have substantial variation
with cost of care sending up over 50,000
easily for some of the patients after
instituting the early recognition
program that median cost per patient
dropped down to 16,000 and that's a
savings of just under $6,000 patient per
patient with early recognition so $6,000
can save a substantial amount of money
to your hospital when it's per patient
and you can get a lot of lab testing
done in there I also mentioned that the
length of stay and overall mortality
actually drops so that's the graph on
the right where you can see the early
recognition program consistent with what
we know early recognition and treatment
of sepsis improves outcome and reduces
hospital stay this is something which
was also streamed go to hospital who had
introduced their sepsis six bundle where
they're giving defined treatment all
within one hour and interesting things
happened with their their project
actually they found that they had
relatively poor compliance and this is
something which is prevalent throughout
the literature actually that you have a
lot of places who Institute sepsis
recognition programs and have poor
compliance so getting folks actually
recognized syndromes and coordinate the
care among the team could be incredibly
challenging so at Good Hope Hospital
this sort of inadvertently created a
control group and a non control group so
that group of patients not receiving the
one hour bundle who had an almost 40%
mortality rate are actually patients on
those same floors at the same time they
instituted the sepsis bundle just ones
where
this bundle was not actually received
within the one hour and so that created
that nice control group where they can
really see the impact of early
recognition treatment for those
receiving the bundle the final cost
analysis from this was to fewer critical
care bed days and three point four fewer
hospital bed days which led to an
estimating savings of about five
thousand pounds per patient I have no
idea how much that would be in today's
today's dollars but I will also mention
that that reduction in ICU bed days is
something which has consistently been
observed and when I think about the
amount of lab testing we do on our
patients in the ICU and I don't think
I'm alone on this just diminishing the
amount of time patients spend in the ICU
would actually probably reduce the
amount of testing I do in my lab even if
it means bringing in an additional assay
to do it so where does this leave us
what is the labs role in sepsis so this
is how I like to think about it we have
our way of our clinician whether they're
the emergency department clinician the
ICU clinician and they're confronted
with a patient who may or may not have
sepsis clinical syndrome which is
incredibly challenging to diagnose they
this clinician knows the literature they
know the problem with over prescribing
unnecessary antibiotics they know the
long term cost the increased mortality
the increased expense just in the
antibiotics but they also know the
literature in terms of how much
mortality increases every hour that they
delay and so they're sort of faced with
this this difficult choice of deciding
what to do with the patient and I really
feel like the labs job is to make sure
that that clinician has all of the
information we can possibly give them in
a time frame which allows them to
integrate that information and make a
more informed decision and this is
something where I don't think
one lab test is ever going to be the
definitive marker of sepsis it's always
going to be a data point which fits into
the overall clinical scenario
so this clinician might be confronted
with the patient who they feel strongly
needs antibiotics and even in the face
of a Lowepro calcitonin possibly because
recent sceptic onset and the
procalcitonin hasn't had a chance to
increase yet they're still going to give
antibiotics our job is not to give this
result which they must follow it's to
give more information so that more often
than not as they integrate that into
their decision-making process they're
making the right decision and so with
that include the work cited and I would
be happy to take any questions you might
have
thank you dr. Hayden for that
informative presentation before we get
started on the question and answer
session I would like to remind our
audience how to submit questions you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions as we
can okay our first question is dr.
Hayden as you stated during your
presentation the days of orphan
instruments are behind the efficiency
and quality focused labs of today and
tomorrow
given that what other high medical value
biomarkers do you look to to adopt on
Rochas Kibaki 411 that will make a
significant impact in patient care
this is something I thought about a good
bit and you know the easy answer might
be as many as I can get on there but the
more honest answer is I think that there
are certain ones where we know that
patients are actively awaiting care
based on the result of that assay and
those are ideal ones to put on that
Betty 4:11 plot
so the immediate ones that come to mind
are certainly going to be procalcitonin
it's definitely going to be
interoperative parathyroid hormone so
for those not familiar with it
io PTH is going to be a marker of cancer
in the parathyroid and they're going to
do a parathyroidectomy where they remove
what they think is all of the tumor and
then they look for levels of the IO PTH
to drop consistent with the successful
surgery so when we get those samples
there's a patient somewhere on a table
lying opened with an entire surgical
team waiting for those results to decide
if they're done with the surgery where
they need to continue so that is exactly
the sort of essay I want to have on that
platform and then in addition absolutely
our cardiac markers okay next question
but roll with a lab play in educating
clinician from PCT what results mean how
to use it etc and who will be serving in
that capacity will you be putting
together a committee to share in this
responsibility yeah so so I definitely
think that you know speaking with the
clinicians is always an interesting
situation where you have some really
great interactions and other times it's
not as great the best advice I've gotten
which we try to follow and we'll try to
follow is to find our clinician
advocates our champions those folks on
our sepsis committee on the NG microbial
stewardship committee this is going to
be hospital epidemiology some of the ID
specialists who are aware of the
literature and are aware of how helpful
this testing has proven to be in
published studies and working with them
to have them champion this I think is
one of the most important things that
labs can do and then beyond that making
sure that you're offering a service
which meets the needs you don't want to
be in a position of proposing to offer
this testing and yet you have like we do
11 hour turnaround time and that's not
going to be terribly helpful so
definitely make sure that you're your
own internal processes meet the clinical
needs and then find your your clinical
champion possibly on those sepsis
committees or into microbial stewardship
committees are a great place to start
next question do we understand why a
hormone for calcium homeostasis is
released in response to infection that's
a very good question yes so
procalcitonin is the pro hormone of
calcitonin but it has nothing to do with
the calcium regulation and it's actually
secreted by different cells although
although I have seen some case reports
of elevated PSG's with different
malignancies but to answer the question
I'm not sure why procalcitonin is
secreted in response next question I am
a microbiologist and I am not familiar
with IO PTH what is it
yes oh sorry I realized I was falling
into the trap of using abbreviations
which aren't always commonplace so I opt
H as I'd mentioned is interoperative
parathyroid hormone so this is going to
be used as a marker of malignancy to
decide if tumor removal is successful or
if they need to continue the PCT replace
lactate that's another good one so
lactate has definitely made its way into
the CMS core measures and lactate in
general is a very good marker of end
organ damage
so I certainly don't see it replacing
lactate because it would still be
important to know if your patient has
reached that level but I also don't see
it excluding the use of procalcitonin
it's a procalcitonin is going to be an
earlier marker of septic damage whereas
I think lactate is more a sign that
damage has already been done
so no I don't see it replacing I also
think they tried to mention in in the
last slide substance is such a
challenging diagnosis that there's no
one test which is going to be excellent
for it and replace all the others it
really is making sure we get the best
data possible which might include
multiple markers next question does
every patient get PCT or do you have
exclusion criteria do not any particular
exclusion criteria other than clinical
presentation and so I would not
recommend every patient get
procalcitonin you know I think pretest
probability is something we always need
to keep in mind when we're doing when
we're doing testing but if there is a
suspicion for potential sepsis then I do
think that procalcitonin should
definitely be ordered there are cases
where procalcitonin can be complicated
by other ongoing factors so our
department of surgery for instance is
incredibly interested in markers of
infections and and subsets
they're very interested in procalcitonin
and while it has some utility there it's
worth keeping in mind that major trauma
including large surgery can actually
temporarily elevate profound
tonin and then procalcitonin can be
elevated neonates just an early stages
of life so you certainly need to be
considerate of the patience that's being
tested on and whether there might be
confounders which would reduce its
diagnostic accuracy dr. Hayden does
procalcitonin predict fungal sepsis yeah
so there is some very interesting work
which I've recently seen and let me say
the literature on procalcitonin is
tremendous so my apologies for those who
were hoping to hear many of its other
uses you'll note I didn't even talk
about the de-escalation of antimicrobial
therapy and anybody who'd just read the
recent Lancet article or the SAPS trial
is probably hoping to hear that
another area is going to be is going to
be I'm sorry I just blanked on the
question would you repeat the question
again yeah it's one moment I was I asked
does procalcitonin predict fungal sepsis
yes I'm sorry I got myself on a tangent
and you can see what my residents have
to deal with with me there was some
recent literature looking at potential
for procalcitonin to discriminate
between gram positive gram negatives as
well as fungal infections so fungal
infections it will rise up in response
to the fungal infections and there's
been very limited data to suggest that
perhaps the magnitude of increase might
actually be somewhat informative of the
nature of the infection but that
absolutely remains to be seen whether
that's going to be borne out by larger
larger studies and trials but answers
the question is yes you will get a rise
in procalcitonin okay what advantage
does PCT have over lactate what
advantages
you have over lactate so you know
lactate is elected is going to be a good
indicator of end organ damage there's
other markers for mortality right the
sequential substance related organ
failure sofa score SOF a for instance
which is going to look at creatinine
bilirubin all of these things which just
like lactate our markers of end organ
failure I do think we want to be asking
ourselves do we really want to use
markers of organ damage to know when we
need to be concerned right you want to
wait for your car to break down before
you know that you should have maybe
change the oil or something like that so
that's really how I see procalcitonin
contributing as as an earlier marker you
don't necessarily have to wait or the
end organ damage which is caused by that
uncontrolled immune response you can
hopefully start to earlier detect
indications of the immune response
through elevated levels of procalcitonin
now dr. Hayden are you planning on
moving this to the roche analyzers to
improve t18 I would say it is twofold
the first is definitely to improve the
turnaround time the second really is
going to be the operational savings
we're in the midst of getting ready for
our c AP inspection window and so i'm
thinking carefully about all of our
potential vulnerabilities for citations
and it's amazing if you just go through
the cap checklist how many items are
there for each instrument you have in
the lab and so a chance to do platform
consolidation to have a single analyzer
which can do some of these analytes like
the i/o PTH the troponin procalcitonin
etc saves us a substantial amount of
work and then I only have to Train folks
on a single in
ermand I only have to have a single
interface yeah so it is the turn around
time improvement but I suspect we're
going to realize some very helpful
operational savings in the ROC curves
you showed for a better SN and SP with
PCT over lactate other what time points
for PCT measurement were used to
diagnose step so that's a good question
I'm actually not
I don't recall the time points used so
PCT is going to rise up relatively
quickly you know within six hours they
say so it would be early time point this
would not be days later and I would have
to look my suspicion is most of the
trials I've looked at which have been
prospective has done it at what we would
call time zero so time suspicions of
sepsis but there are certainly been some
retrospective looks which have used
whatever time it was ordered so I'm
sorry I'm not not sure dr. Hayden
are there different manufacturers that
offer PCT PCT testing oh yes absolutely
certainly there are there are other
manufacturers who offer there are not as
many and for a while there was really
only one for a very long time but there
certainly are others we currently use
use the Vitis instrument which is broke
out Sedona and have been using that for
quite a while in our our batched format
so there are there are certainly other
options you know and I think each lab
needs to evaluate what works best for
them you know for we're a relatively
high volume lab so we're looking at over
10 million chemistry tests I have a
large amount of outreach business but
also our relatively large hospital
business and so we have unique
challenges and advantages
and so this is the platform that works
works best for us we think moving to the
roche solution but there are other
options out there many ER Doc's are
taught that lactate is the best
indicator of sepsis and that PCT is not
ready for primetime due to the lack of
studies as of 2014
do you have any comments on that yeah I
you know since I'm being webinar cast
and recorded I'm gonna try to be a
little cautious here but inevitably I
guess I said enough
stupid things I might as well just go
for it I find this interesting situation
occurs when I'm speaking with some
clinicians about procalcitonin and I
would say that those who feel they least
need it are the ones who most need it
perhaps it's just some sort of
dunning-kruger effect where you know not
recognizing how complicated and
challenging substances means that you
think you're always right but the
reality is that absolutely there's a
perception out there that folks are
doing a very good job with sepsis and
you know in some cases that absolutely
is the case and as I said I'd never
recommend somebody based treatment
solely off of a lab test clinical
evaluation of the patient is still going
to be paramount but I also think that
there is a bit of hubris involved that
folks think they already have all the
biomarkers they already have all the
information they need they're making the
best possible decisions and that is
especially apparent when I talk with
many of the more informed clinicians
such as infectious disease specialist
Hospital epidemiologist those who are
aware of the challenge of sepsis and the
performance of actually being able to
recognize it by experienced clinicians
so that that's where I think finding
those more informed clinicians and
having them help you convey the message
is really important
I hate in the next question is three
parts would you make the test only
available to certain Hospital locations
clinician would you put a limit in how
many PCT can be requested in 24 hours
and when you implement the test how do
you measure that it is being used
effectively and as intended these are
all three great questions and if you
don't mind I'm gonna get asked just to
repeat one at a time but let me say
right off this is really asking about
the lab utilization culture in your
Hospital which is going to vary
tremendously across the u.s. not to
mention if you go across the world who's
speaking with somebody recently he was
telling about some of the situations in
some of the European countries where the
labs have the ability to have more say
over what's ordered and what's not so
I'll answer each individual one but it
definitely needs to be put in the
context of your your institutions labs
utilization culture so I think the first
one was would we allow just anybody to
order it is that correct would you make
the tests only available to certain
Hospital locations clinician so in my
hospital we would not we would have that
available to be ordered at clinician
discretion however we do sometimes
monitor and so will sometimes do
targeted interventions to inform folks
if we see actually you're ordering a lot
of procalcitonin and it's probably not
right for your patient population but it
would be available for anybody and then
I think there was a question - about the
frequency that we would define of
limiting would you limit how many PCT
could be requested in the 24 hour period
yeah that's a very good question I've
been working with our household
epidemiology and members of sepsis
community to define you know how often
should it be ordered to give some of
these guidelines one could imagine
setting up an order set and certainly
something I thought about where the
clinician place single procalcitonin
order and you know let's say the time
zero and day four order are sort of
already in the system so we will
absolutely be looking at ways to guide
people towards appropriate ordering but
I won't necessarily put initial hard
stops should they choose to order every
two hours and yes it pains me to say
that but that's not my institutions
culture partially because we've had very
good success doing sort of educational
initiatives and not doing it if you're
at a place you know I think Kaiser does
a great job of sort of determining who
can order what and when then that's
absolutely something you could think
about in the last part of that question
when you implement the test how do you
measure that it is being used
effectively and as intended yeah yeah so
in terms of looking at how it's being
used and whether it's being used as its
intended so those would be a lot of
internal quality improvement Quality
Assurance projects so you saw dr.
Michael Novak did the work looking at
the turnaround time for procalcitonin
we've had other residents who have been
interested in looking at how tests are
being used and its utility and a lot of
times it comes from the clinical
services - they have residents and
fellows who take an interest in that and
so that's that's how we would try to do
that is to partner with folks and look
at those qi projects certainly in
consultation with our IRB because
sometimes that blurs line between
research and pure quality improvement
dr. Hayden based on your presentation
CMS currently does not require PCT as
part of its process to diagnose sepsis
when do you proceed CMS adopting this
PCT testing into their recommendation
and why hasn't it been recommended up to
this point yeah yeah that's a great
great question I don't I don't know
where it might go and honestly from
conversations I've had I'm not sure
where the sepsis bundles are gonna go
they were highly debated in terms of are
these the best standards I think there's
good universal consensus that we need to
implement better standards of care for
sepsis at some places and we need to
start encouraging those but what are
those standards and so I do think that
that's one of the reasons that the
sepsis Corps bundles has some of those I
would call them more traditional you
know the lactates and that absolutely
part of it when you're doing introducing
a bundle which is controversial you try
to leave as many controversial things as
possible out of it and you know in
addition there's also the issue of you
don't want to implement a standard of
care that every hospital can't meet
right so they do consider the
availability of testing and you know we
saw in the poll that not everybody is
doing procalcitonin and so to just
require it as part of a core measure
it's going to be challenging so I think
increasing adoption of procalcitonin
would and having it more widely
available could potentially impact that
but more importantly I think there's
going to be a lot of discussion and
review of what these core measures do in
terms of improving patient care and
whether we need to rethink what all is
included rethink some of the
interventions we think the time points
hopefully define time zero definitely
going to be an evolving process
I believe we have time for a few more
questions which is the best analytic
method to test PCP which is the best
analytic method to detect PCT so let me
give the caveat that one of my special
side interest is is mass spectrometry
and so whenever asked what's the best
analytic method I always have that
fallback
always mass spectrometry but I don't see
us implementing peptide based proteomics
large-scale with under one hour
turnaround time so no it
you know it really is going to depend on
what the requirements for use are you
need to be able to detect down to the
low levels you need to have good
precision on your assays because as you
can imagine a lot of folks are using
this to predict 28-day mortality risk in
which case they're looking at the
difference between two levels so the
precision is essential lack of
interferences going to be important and
then beyond that whatever platform
allows you to to get out the results in
a clinically usable time frame yeah I
hope I did an adequate job not answering
that question but talking for a while
dr. Hayden how frequently would you
recommend checking a patient from
procalcitonin level yeah so it's going
to depend I think that there are
different clinical scenarios and I think
that something that labs can start to do
actively is to inform how this testing
could and should be used so I'll just
give one scenario you have procalcitonin
down around 0.2 0.3 in a patient with a
very high clinical suspicion sepsis I
don't think it's unreasonable to retest
that level in six hours to see if maybe
you just caught them early and just like
it all at the same time if you have a
patient with a procalcitonin greater
than 10
I'm not sure if there's much utility in
retesting that six hours later so I
think that lads need to think carefully
about about the algorithm so ours which
were envisioning is you know an elevated
procalcitonin does not require a
follow-up it's not right away not within
that day and certainly you would want to
retest again within that day for time
frame but then also we're starting to
look at how can we use this or angel
microbial stewardship and so that's
going to define those time points at
what point can we check those patients
with elevated procalcitonin to make
decisions on discontinuing antibiotics
so that'll primarily be based on that
SAP's trial which came out which we'll
be speaking with hospital genealogy
about we've had so many great questions
coming in and we have time for one last
question dr. Hayden what is the added
value of PCT compared to a cheap C or P
result yeah I think that's actually it's
interesting that the lactate came up
because the CRP is the one that I get
more often than anything you know it's
hard to deny the advantages of CRP there
on our automated platforms they're dirt
cheap we can run them all the time and
they certainly are a nonspecific marker
of inflammation so you know in the right
patient you're going to see some value
there I think the real utility of
procalcitonin is its improved
specificity or substance so that you
have a lot more confidence that that
marker you're following is a better
indicator of the what's going on with
your patient from a sceptic standpoint
so you know nonspecific inflammatory
processes are far less likely to
elevate procalcitonin than they are CRP
and that's that's pretty well played out
in the literature as well that you know
these these patients with elevated
procalcitonin typically also have
elevated CRPS but a lot of patients with
low normal procalcitonin also have
elevated CRP and then the kinetics of
CRP is also going to be going to be
different so last I was reading over the
CRP lag behind procalcitonin so one
could argue that if you're actually
catching the patient early enough PCT
might be elevated while the CRP hasn't
risen up yet I'm not sure how often that
is in a real-world standpoint but I
really think it's specificity is the big
point I would like to once again thank
dr. Joshua Hayden for his presentation
dr. Hayden Jimmy final comments well you
know you have to say that from my
standpoint I'm very excited for this
assay coming out on this particular
platform I remember when I heard about
it my eyes sort of lit up I think what
you have is this true random-access
analyzer where clearly effort has been
made to shorten incubation time so you
can get rapid turnaround times we were
already interested in something like the
e 411 for our I opt H because frankly
it's the perfect analyzer for the sort
of stat assays that you need to offer
and while we were already thinking about
it Roche kind of came and gave us this
gift of validating and getting FDA
clearance for procalcitonin and so they
sort of have this ideal platform for
this biomarker and we're pretty excited
to see how that impacts our hospital and
the care we're able to give our patients
after hayden thank you for your time
today I would also like to thank lab
leaders we're making today's webcast
possible a dedicated discussion guide
will be available with on-demand access
to this webcast on the webinars page of
lab leaders comm with in the coming
weeks you will also find many more
webinars on demand there as well as
information on the next installment of
the lab leaders webinar series and
veiling the future of laboratory
medicine a series of high-impact talks
from lab leaders on the leading edge
during this presentation dr. Katie
Thoren attending clinical chemist at
Memorial sloan-kettering Cancer Center
dr. Marc Rosinski director of
pre-analytical and main chemistry and
director of the clinical pharmacology
analytical laboratory within the
division of clinical pharmacology at
Johns Hopkins University and dr. Joe L
Khoury co-director of clinical chemistry
and clinical chemistry fellowship
program at the Yale New Haven Health
will be teaming up to discuss the future
of immunology precision medicine and big
data in a series of three height impact
presentation please ensure you're
registered on lab leaders comm for full
access today's webcast will also be
available for on-demand viewing through
April 5th 2017 on lab routes you will
receive an email from lab roots alerting
you when this webcast will be available
for replay we invite you to forward that
announcement to your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event thank you
for joining us and we hope to see you
next time until then goodbye